[Musique]
françaises français mes chers
compatriotes
depuis l'attaqué brutale lancée par le
président poutine contre l'ukraine le 24
février les forces russes bombarde kiev
assiègent les villes les plus
importantes du pays
des centaines de civils l'ukrainien ont
d'ores et déjà été tué
des femmes et des enfants
ont été tuées encore ce jour
les jours qui viennent seront
vraisemblablement de plus en plus dur
des centaines de milliers de réfugiés
fuient vers la moldavie la pologne la
roumanie la hongrie la slovaquie et
progressivement le reste de l'europe
dans cette épreuve sans précédent depuis
nombre de décennies nous nous tenons aux
côtés de l'ukraine
je salue ce soir le courage du peuple
ukrainien qui résistent sous le feu des
armes et en votre nom j'adresse au
président volodymyr zielinski le soutien
fraternel de la france
il est aujourd'hui à la tête de son
peuple si courageux
le visage de l'honneur de la liberté de
la bravoure
ni la france ni l'europe ni le cren ni
l'alliance atlantique n'ont voulu cette
guerre nous avons au contraire tout fait
pour l'éviter vous le savez j'ai depuis
2010 est conduit un dialogue exigeant et
constant avec le président poutine et
face à l'aggravation des tensions je me
suis rendu à moscou puis à kiev les 7 et
8 février dernier pour rechercher des
alternatives un conflit armé plusieurs
autres dirigeants européens ont
d'ailleurs accompagner cet effort le
président des états unis d'amérique à
manifester quant à lui sa disponibilité
pour négocier après avoir rencontré
physiquement le président poutine en
juin 2021 à genève c'est donc bien seul
et de manière délibérée que renie en un
à un les engagements pris devant la
communauté des nations le président
poutine a choisi la guerre
cette guerre n'est pas un conflit entre
l'otan et l'occident d'une part et la
russie d'autre part comme certains
peuvent l'écrire
il n'y a pas de troupes ni de base de
l'otan en ukraine ce sont des mensonges
la russie n'est pas agressé elle est
l'agresseur
cette guerre est encore moins comme une
propagande insoutenable voudrait le
faire penser une lutte contre le nazisme
c'est un mensonge une insulte à
l'histoire de la russie et de l'ukraine
à la mémoire de nos aînés qui ont
combattu côte à côte contre le nazisme
les dirigeants russes s'en prennent à la
mémoire de la shoah en ukraine comme ils
s'en prennent en russie à la mémoire des
crimes du stalinisme
cette guerre est le fruit d'un esprit de
revanche nourri d'une lecture
révisionniste de l'histoire de l'europe
qui voudraient la renvoyer aux heures
les plus sombres des empires des
invasions des exterminations
à cette violation flagrante de
l'intégrité du territoire et de la
souveraineté d'un pays européens la
france et l'europe ont répondu
immédiatement
unanimement fermement
nous l'avons fait en étroite
coordination avec les britanniques les
canadiens les américains les japonais et
tant d'autres pays
d'abord en soutenant le peuple ukrainien
par des convois humanitaires ainsi que
par la livraison de matériels et
d'équipements pour se défendre
ensuite en agissant avec les autres
nations pour que les dirigeants russes
entendent que le choix de la guerre
mettraient leur pays ont dans des
peuples et de l'histoire
une résolution a été votée au conseil de
sécurité des nations unies sur les
violations du droit international
commises par moscou et cet après midi
même l'assemblée générale des nations
unies a condamné par un vote écrasant
cette agression
la communauté internationale a ainsi
montré son unité
les équipes sportives de russie ont été
exclus des grandes compétitions
internationales et nombre de grands
événements sportifs et culturels ont été
annulés
nous continuons et continuerons un
travail acharné afin de conduire sur
tous les continents les nations a
condamné l'invasion a exigé le
cessez-le-feu et le respect des
opérations humanitaires sur le sol
ukrainien
nous avons pris de manière rapide et
proportionnée des sanctions à l'égard de
la russie et de ses dirigeants
les avoirs de plusieurs centaines de
personnalités russes proches du pouvoir
ont ainsi été gelés en france et à
l'étranger
plusieurs grandes banques russes ont été
exclues des systèmes de paiements
internationaux rendant impossible nombre
de transactions et entraînant la chute
du rouble
les organes de propagande russe viennent
de cesser d'émettre en europe
sur le terrain nous sommes donné les
moyens de protéger nos ressortissants en
organisant le transfert de notre
ambassade d'une ville l'autre en ukraine
et en permettant à tous les français ou
binationaux qui le souhaitent de pouvoir
quitter le pays dans les meilleurs
délais et je veux ici en votre nom
remercier l'ensemble des diplomates
policiers militaires et agents de l'état
qui continue de mener cet effort et
prennent en charge nos compatriotes en
moldavie et sur les principaux points de
sortie du territoire ukrainien
je remercie aussi l'ensemble des
journalistes qui couvrent avec courage
le conflit et oeuvres ainsi à la liberté
d'information de tous les citoyens du
monde
enfin nous avons participé à l'effort
dans le cadre de l'otan pour protéger la
sécurité et la souveraineté de nos
alliés européens en renforçant la
présence militaire que nous avons déjà
dans les états baltes et dans la région
ainsi plusieurs centaines de soldats
français sont arrivés hier sur le sol de
la roumanie
initiatives diplomatiques
sanctions contre les dirigeants
politiques et économiques de la russie
soutien à la population ukrainienne vont
ainsi se poursuivre et s'intensifier
avec pour objectif de obtenir l'arrêt
des combats
et pour autant nous ne sommes pas en
guerre contre la russie nous savons tous
ce qui nous lie à ce grand peuple
européen qu'est le peuple russe qui a
tant sacrifié durant la seconde guerre
mondiale pour sauver l'europe de l'abyme
nous sommes aujourd'hui aux côtés de
tous les russes qui refusant qu'une
guerre indignes soient menées en leur
nom ont l'esprit de responsabilité et le
courage de défendre la paix et qui le
font savoir en russie et ailleurs
c'est pour cela que si j'ai change
constamment avec le président et lynch
qui j'ai aussi choisi de rester en
contact et resterai en contact
autant que je le peux et autant que
c'est nécessaire avec le président
poutine pour chercher sans relâche à le
convaincre de renoncer aux armes pour
aider autant que la france le peut dans
le cadre des pourparlers en cours et
pour prévenir la contagion et
l'élargissement du conflit autant que
nous le pouvons
les équilibres de notre continent comme
plusieurs aspects de notre quotidien
sont d'ores et déjà bouleversé par cette
guerre et connaîtront des changements
profonds dans les mois qui viennent
notre europe en sera bousculée j'aurai
l'occasion d'y revenir
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
réfugiés venant d'ukraine sont et seront
accueillis sur notre continent
la france prendra sa part et je veux ici
d'ores et déjà remercier nos villes nos
villages qui ont commencé à se mobiliser
remercier nos associations
qui aussi oeuvre pour accueillir dans
les meilleures conditions
nous nous organisons et nous prendrons
soin de celles et ceux qui rejoignent
notre sol pour être protégé
la france prendra aussi sa part en
accueillant les enfants forcés à l'exil
séparer de leurs pairs restés combattre
et ce en étroite collaboration avec les
associations les organisations non
gouvernementales qui oeuvrent déjà sur
place et dans notre pays
notre agriculture notre industrie
nombre de secteurs économiques souffrent
et vont souffrir soit parce qu'ils
dépendent des importations de matières
premières venues de russie ou d'ukraine
soit parce qu'ils exportent vers ces
pays
notre croissance aujourd'hui au plus
haut sera immanquablement affecté
le renchérissement du prix du pétrole du
gaz des matières premières a et aura des
conséquences sur notre pouvoir d'achat
demain le prix du plein d'essence le
montant de la facture de chauffage le
coût de certains produits risque de
s'alourdir encore alors face à ses
conséquences économiques et sociales
je n'ai et n'aurait qu'une boussole vous
protégez nous y poserons les secteurs
économiques les plus exposés en
recherchant de nouveaux fournisseurs de
nouveaux débouchés commerciaux et c'est
à cette fin que je me suis entretenu
avec des homologues américains européens
moyen-orientaux nous apporterons des
réponses adaptées face aux perturbations
des flux commerciaux et à l'augmentation
des prix
et j'ai demandé aux premiers ministres
d'élaborer pour les prochains jours un
plan de résilience économique et social
pour répondre à toutes ces difficultés
mais ne nous trompons pas
ces événements n'auront pas seulement
des conséquences immédiates à la trame
de quelques semaines ils sont le signal
d'un changement d'époque
la guerre en europe n'appartient plus à
nos livres d'histoire ou nos livres
d'école elle est là sous nos yeux
la démo si n'est plus considérée comme
un régime incontestable elle est remise
en cause sous nos yeux
notre liberté celle de nos enfants n'est
plus un acquis elle est plus que jamais
un système de courage un combat de
chaque instant
à ce retour brutal du tragique dans
l'histoire nous nous devons de répondre
par des décisions historiques
notre pays amplifiera donc
l'investissement dans sa défense décidé
dès 2017 et poursuivra sa stratégie
d'indépendance et d'investissement dans
son économie sa recherche son innovation
déjà renforcé à la lumière de la
pandémie
notre europe dans cette épreuve démontre
comme elle l'a fait ces derniers mois
une unité remarquable
elle doit désormais accepté de payer le
prix de la paix de la liberté de la
démocratie
elle doit investir davantage pour moins
dépendre des autres continents et
pouvoir décider pour elles mêmes en
d'autres termes devenir une puissance
plus indépendantes plus souveraine
puissance économique d'abord nous ne
pouvons plus dépendre des autres pour
nous nourrir nous soigner nous informer
nous financer voilà pourquoi dans le
prolongement des décisions prises au
plus fort de la pandémie avec le plan de
relance européen nous devrons promouvoir
un nouveau modèle économique fondé sur
l'indépendance et le progrès puissance
énergétique ensuite nous ne pouvons plus
dépendre des autres et notamment du gaz
russe pour nous déplacer nous chauffer
faire fonctionner nos usines voilà
pourquoi après avoir décidé pour la
france le développement des énergies
renouvelables et la construction de
nouveaux réacteurs nucléaires je
défendrai une stratégie d'indépendance
énergétique européenne
puissance de paix enfin nous ne pouvons
dépendre des autres pour nous défendre
que ce soit sur terre sur mer sous la
mer dans les airs dans l'espace ou le
cyber espace
à cet égard notre défense européenne
doit franchir une nouvelle étape
je réunirai les différences mars
prochain à versailles les chefs d'état
et de gouvernement européens lors d'un
sommet qui aura à décider sur ces sujets
d'ores et déjà notre europe a montré
unités et détermination
elle est entrée dans une nouvelle ère il
nous faut poursuivre
mes chers compatriotes
la guerre en ukraine marque une rupture
pour notre continent et nos générations
je sais combien elle vous inquiètent
légitimement
elle nous mobilise et nous imposera de
prendre des décisions
je vous en rendrez compte
cette guerre vient aussi percuter notre
vie démocratique et la campagne
électorale qui s'ouvre officiellement à
la fin de cette semaine
cette campagne permettra un débat
démocratique
important pour la nation mais qui ne
nous empêchera pas de nous réunir sur
l'essentiel
je sais pouvoir compter sur vous votre
attachement à la liberté à l'égalité
et à la fraternité
à la place de la france dans le monde
je ne cesserai jamais de les défendre et
de les porter au en votre nom
vive la république
vive la france